much nike so um i'm just going to
continue where we left off so at uh
last lecture we switched from talking
about vector valued uh uh functions on
the discrete cube to talking about
boolean functions which is basically the
exact opposite
and i just want to remind you what we
said last time
so i'm going to call a boolean function
for simplicity function from the
discrete cube to 0 1 rather than minus 1
1
that makes no difference and what i
tried to
argue last time is that there's really
only one thing as far as
we're concerned that's special about
boolean functions and which is that if
you square them
right 0 1 squared is still only 0 1 so
the function remains the same if you
square it and in particular that means
that the variance of the function
f up to a factor two right so the
variance of the explanation of f minus
the expansion of s squared
is equal to the expectation of the
absolute value of f minus the
expectation of f without the square
right so the nice thing about volume
function is that you can remove or add
the square
um and you get the same thing um
so um now what does the punch inequality
say for boolean function the punch
inequality says that the variance of f
is bounded by the expected square
gradient of f right
but for a boolean function the variance
of f is equal to the
absolute mean deviation of f the
expectation of f minus the expectation
of f right so i just wrote here
in the third line um i wrote um
over here um i wrote just a punch
inequality where
we place the left-hand side instead of
writing the variance of f i wrote
the expectation of f minus the
expectation right
so um now we saw last time that this is
a very sub-optimal inequality for
boolean functions right because
um for example even for a simple
function like the majority function this
is very very far off
and i tried to explain last time that
there's a reason for this which is you
know
on the left hand side you don't have a
square but on the right hand side you
have a square
so really what this is suggesting is
that the punch inequality is simply the
wrong inequality to look at when you're
looking at boolean functions we should
try to look for an l1 version of the
punker inequality
right where we also don't have a square
over here and we proved exactly such an
inequality right
so this inequality over here this l1
version of the punch inequality has
nothing to do with boolean functions
right this is true for any function of
the discrete cube but for boolean
functions this inequality is much much
better
than the punch of inequality because on
the left hand side you don't lose
anything right because for boolean
functions the left hand side is the same
for the punch of inequality in this one
but on the right hand side we have
gained a square and that's exactly what
so for example for the for this
inequality over here um
the the for the majority function you
get a sharp result up to universal
constant
and i proved this inequality for you
last time in two lines because i just
followed immediately from the linear
non-linear principle that we've already
developed for vector-valued functions
um now so uh that's one reason why for
boolean functions it's not a good idea
to use the plunker inequality
now i want to argue that there's a
completely different reason um also very
well known
that for boolean functions the punch
inequality gives the wrong answer
and that second reason is that maybe the
poncharine equality itself
uh is suboptimal
so the reason number one is not state
saying that the punk herring equality is
suboptimal
it's just saying that the punkering
equality is the wrong inequality right
you should have used an l1 version of
the punker inequality
but the second reason is saying that
even if we stuck with the punk arena
quality we use the variance not the mean
the the absolute deviation
maybe you can improve on the poincare
inequality itself right
now this might mix together a bit when
you think about boolean functions
because again for boolean function the
mean deviation
and the variance are the same order but
when i mean the poncarena quality of
suboptimal i mean even for functions
that are not boolean
maybe it is true that the puncher
inequality is sub-optimal that we can do
better
and if you can do that for general
functions then maybe that improvement
will also help you deal with boolean
functions
so let me try to explain um why the
poncharine equality can be suboptimal it
turns out there's really only one reason
why the puncher inequality can be
suboptimal
and in order to explain this we should
really go back to the proof of the
puncher inequality so recall how did we
prove the poincare inequality
so i'm now going back to the very first
lecture right so what we did is we use
this interpolation method
and the interpolation method there was a
key
identity which showed up which was
actually an equality for the variance
we had when we applied the interpolation
we wrote the variance of f
as explanation of f squared minus the
expectation of f squared and we
interpolated using the heat semi group
and then we got an identity
which said that this was equal to the
integral of zero to infinity of the
gradient of ptf
squared rather than the gradient of f
squared right if we had the grain of f
squared on the left hand side we would
have
uh the punk rain equality but this is
not an inequality this is actually an
identity
right so so far there was no loss
right so if the poncarene cloud is
suboptimal
then we have to lose on the next step
and what was what did we do in the next
step
in the next step we used that the
gradient of the semi group
is actually decaying exponentially
right we had such an inequality which we
proved using some explicit computations
right and if you plug this inequality
into your actually i'm missing a factor
two
if you plug this inequality into that
identity then the integral of two e to
the minus two t is just equal to one and
you get exactly the poincare inequality
right so because the first guide over
here the
the is an identity the only place where
you can lose is in the second part where
you show that the semi group is actually
forgetting its initial condition at an
exponential rate so
how could you hope to gain on the um how
could you hope to gain
um on the puncher inequality how could
we hope to improve
right well look at the second thing it's
saying that's the
that's the behavior of the semi group as
a function of the initial condition is
decaying exponentially
like this well it could be so for a
general function f then you can't beat
this for example for a linear function f
this was actually equality
remember particle inequality was
equality for linear functions right
so the only hope that you can have is
that for certain types of functions
maybe boolean functions right or maybe
under other conditions maybe for certain
types of functions
the gradient forgets its initial
condition at a much faster rate
okay so let me draw some sort of
hypothetical picture
suppose that the true behavior for a
given function if the true behavior
wasn't this
but you actually became much much faster
maybe you reach zero or almost zero
at some time t star right so you will
never
actually reach zero at a finite time but
just for sake of argument think that we
almost reach zero at time t
star and t star is very very short much
shorter than you would expect from e to
the minus two t
right well if that were to be the case
right
if this were to be the case
if this happens then you see in this
integral i don't have to
integral all the way integrate all the
way to infinity we just have to
integrate up to t star right because
after t
star i've already reached equilibrium
right for the given function
f right so then
you would actually have that the
variance of f is of order
not integral from zero to infinity but
it just would be avoided integral from
zero to t star
and this guy over here is bounded by t
star right times the expectation of the
gradient
sorry of the gradient of f
square so the poncarena quality you had
here are number one
right but if for some given function f
um it so happens that the semi group
decays much much more quickly that it
already reaches equilibrium at time t
star then you can replace that constant
one by a constant of order t
star and so if you imagine that you have
a function f that that reaches
equilibrium at a very very short time
let's say t
star is of order little one then you
have here significantly beat the poncare
inequality
right and in a sense this is not only
one way to beat the punk brain equality
this turns out to be basically the only
way to beat the punker inequality
because we have an identity in this
first identity right so you can reverse
this argument as well
right so um this is really the only way
that we can hope to beat the punch
inequality if
for the given function that we're
interested in um we reach
equilibrium much faster than this rate e
to the minus two
and this mechanism that i've just shown
you here
um whether implicitly or explicitly
is behind all of the beautiful results
in the literature
uh um improving the poncare inequality
right so there's a long history of this
so the
there's the famous khan khalidinian
there is a famous theorem of telegram
different one
about the l1 l2 inequality then
um there is i should single out a
beautiful paper by benjamini
kalai
this i'm putting a box around it because
to my knowledge this is really the place
where this picture that i've drawn here
was made very very explicit right so in
these earlier
results they were using fourier analysis
it wasn't so clear that this was going
on but in this paper
nikolai sharma is really damned this is
what's going on and it really clarified
the situation
and then there is a a variant of these
results due to
uh two um in two papers phallic
samodnicki
and rossignol
these are two different separate papers
by two separate groups that happen to
have discovered exactly the same proof
so this is another variance of uh the
same ideas
that's it okay so there's a whole list
of ideas over here
um so um this is
basically the way that you can be the
poker inequality so let me write down a
theorem of this kind
okay and i'm going to write down the
theorem in the form that it was derived
by
by these last two groups because this is
going to be the most convenient
for us going forward but it's uh you
know very you know the other results
over here are just variants of the same
theory
okay so um it just depends on exactly
how you arrange the inequality
okay so let me write down this theorem
so um
here's the theorem of phallic
samurotnitsky and ross
okay so again this is not a theorem
that's specific to boolean functions
right this is a theorem that holds for
any
real valued function on the discrete
cube right
so um what is the poincare inequality
remember the ponca inequality says that
the variance of if
is bounded let me leave some space by
the expectation
of the gradient of f squared right
that's the poincare in the code
and what i said is that if you have this
decay that happens very quickly then you
win in the constant
so let me write in the constant here
so the constant is log
so there is here some constant let me
write the variance of
f divided by the sum
i is 1 to n of the expectation of the
absolute value of tif
squared maybe let me put a constant here
and let me put a constant here okay just
for the constant here i know the right
hand side i think is 2 and on the
left-hand side i can't remember exactly
what it is okay but
um let me write such an inequality um
and the point of this theorem is that
this quantity over here is just the t
star that i wrote on the previous slide
sorry it's the one over t star because i
had the t star on the right hand side of
this inequality
right so this quantity over here is of
order 1 over t
star right we'll be of order of this
and what is the point that you see over
here
in the denominator you don't have the
expectation of d i f squared
you have the expectation of d i f with
the square outside
right and remember that for the point
for for boolean function so this is an
inequality that holds for any function
right but for boolean function right
the expectation of the absolute value of
dif with the square outside
is typically much much smaller than the
expectation of the
absolute value of the i f of the square
inside this is just because again the
property that's zero or one squared
equals zero or one
and so what this is showing it's showing
you a general mechanism but in
particular in the case of boolean
functions
it will cause a big improvement on the
poncharine quote
right whereas for example for linear
functions this one over t
star will be of order one and you
haven't gained anything right so
um so that's the idea so this is just a
theorem
okay let me um so
those of you who have done some analysis
of boolean functions will recognize what
these theorems um
help you in the boolean case but let me
just this is a this is a
bootcamp lecture you know let me just
give you a very quick primer on
um the classical story of concolidia
okay so
um this is just an example um
so let's take a boolean function
let's take a function f
from the discrete cube to 0 1 so it's a
boolean function
and think of this as a voting scheme
right so every
voter there are n voters and every one
of them votes for either democrat or
republican
and then the outcome of the election is
either democrat or republican and this
function f describes the rules of the
vote
right now let's make it fair
so let this be fair what i mean is that
the it's equally likely that the outcome
will be democrat or republican
just for simplicity this is just to to
to get some idea
um now what is this expectation
of absolute value of the if now first of
all because
this function takes only the value of
zero or one this is the same as the
expectation of the absolute value of d i
f squared right with the square inside
the expectation right
because zero squared is zero and 1
squared is 1.
and what is this we've already
encountered this quantity
this is called the influence
of voter i right so this is just the
probability
that the outcome will change
if i flips their the i if you flip the
if a bit
right so this says that you know this is
the probability
that if i switch my votes then the
outcome of the election will change
right that's the influence of me right
and every voter has their own
influence so now you might wonder you
know there are many different voting
schemes so what can we say
about the influences of different voters
in a generic voting scheme
right so what would the poncho rain
equality say so the poncharine equality
would say that the variance of if
well that's one quarter in this case
because we have a fair voting scheme
right is bounded by the sum i is one to
n
of the influence let's call it the
influence of voter i
let's call this the influence of voter i
right
and this is of course bounded by n times
the maximum influence over all the
voters
so what this says is that no matter
no matter what voting scheme you have
um if you have n voters no matter what
voting stream you have there will always
be at least one voter
who has influenced more than one over n
right that has more than one over n
probability
that if that voter flips their vote then
the outcome of the election will change
and what can collide in yal realized
is in fact without any additional
assumption this statement can be
improved
in fact the maximal influence
is always greater than some constant
times log n
and basically i don't want to work out
all the little details because an
exercise
but if you repeat this computation i
just did with this improvement
of the poincare inequality then you will
get exactly this extra term log n that i
wrote over there
so that's the point of this
of this theorem if you want or a point
of this theorem that um
you actually you see do significantly
better we made no additional assumptions
except that you have a boolean function
but we see that actually there must have
exist a voter who has significantly more
influence
than you would guess by the poncare
inequality and this is a famous paper of
concord landinian where they proved this
theorem
so this is a very very different
improvement than you would get from the
previous
slide right from the l1 puncher
inequality you know one puncher
inequality wouldn't give you this
improvement
right you need a there's a very
different reason why this theorem is
true and that's because the puncher
inequality itself
is not um is not optimal um
and correspondingly in this theorem it's
not the majority function
that will get you this log n over n the
majority function has one over n as its
influence this is all the influence of
all the voters
so in fact the equality case or the the
near equality case
of this theorem is actually a very
different type of voting scheme it's not
the majority function
it's a so-called voting scheme called
the tribes function it works like this
you know in the united states we have 50
states right
so and every state has a certain number
of voters
so suppose you had the following voting
scheme the democrats win the election if
and only if there
is at least one state in which all the
voters vote unanimously for democrats
this is a very different voting scheme
than a majority um
you know the true voting scheme of the
us is something in between you know it's
this electoral college scheme
and you could also write that as a
function f um but
this is a different voting scheme and it
turns out that in this voting scheme
there is always a voter with
influence at least so um
we have here two very different reasons
to go back to the previous slide
um i told you there's reason one and
reason two
right there's reason one and reason two
why the puncher inequality
is not not a good inequality for boolean
functions
one of them is that it's the wrong
inequality you should go to this l1
inequality
and the other one is that the poncarena
quality itself might be suboptimal
and that's a very different reason
they're capturing two different
probabilistic phenomena
now we have these two different
improvements that for boolean for
different boolean function give you
improvement
and then you might wonder whether one
can combine these two things and get one
theorem that explains all of them
simultaneous
right that's a natural question and um
uh and and a very specific uh conjecture
was made by telegram and it was recently
solved by
uh by ronald and renango so let me write
down what this theory is
so this is a conjecture due to
telecom
97
and it was proved by eldon cross
and let me write it suggestively so the
theorem says the following
for the function f from minus 1 1 to the
n to 0 once for any boolean function
what do we have let me write it
suggestively in terms of the absolute
deviation
but remember that for boolean function
this this mean absolute deviation is
just twice the variance so i could have
just written here the variance
and now i can write here the log of this
constant let me write here a constant
over the sum of the influences squared
so this is what you have
inside this phallic sum of nitsuki etc
inequality
but with a square root
is bounded by some constant times the
expectation of
the the norm of the gradient of the
function
so this is it and you see formally if i
go back to the previous slide if you
look at this result of
falex monitsky and rossignol over here
if i take a square root at both sides i
have almost that result in the next
slide but
then i have the square root outside the
expectation of the square root of the
variance and the square root of the
expectation of the gradient squared
right and the key point in this
inequality is that the square root goes
inside the expectation so i have the
expectation of the norm of the gradient
not the expectation
of the norm of the gradient squared you
see so if this square root term on the
left hand side weren't there
you would have the l1 punker inequality
right
on the other hand if you were to square
this inequality roughly speaking
you would get something like the kai
kankalai li nial or falex mundus rosy
or whatever you want to call it right
and here we've just taken those two
ingredients and stuffed them in one
inequality
and you know uh said a few prayers and
hope that it's true
right and it turns out to be true right
so this is exactly a combination of
these two other inequalities
and i want to try to explain to you why
this inequality is true
okay so that's going to take up the rest
of my um the rest of my lecture
but in fact there is not much to say
conceptually because i've already
explained to you why this inequality is
true
right why was the um why was
the the why can you improve the punch
inequality
it's because the variance decays very
very fast it already decays that order t
star t star being one over log of
something right
the variance is already almost zero why
do you have the l1 punch inequality well
this comes just
very easily from our general theory
right for example from the from the
linear to non-linear principle
so if you want to prove this inequality
the natural thing to try to do is just
to combine these two
things right and that's exactly what
we're going to do okay so
um let me just outline for you so so
i'm not you know i i i i'm not really
adding anything
to what's written in this paper by don
gross except maybe a little bit
simplified presentation
in this paper of eldon gross there's
really two steps
there is step one
is to prove that
the variance of ptf
is bounded by something like t star
times the variance sorry let's let me
put it this way
the variance of ptf is bounded by one
half of the variance of
if so we already basically achieved um
stationarity for
t star of order 1 over log
of this constant over sum i of the
expectation
the i f squared the sum of the
influences squared
right so this is showing that for
um this is showing that for for
um functions f with small influences
um the the you you read stationarity
much much faster than
than you would expect from the punk
brain equality and they do this by
by modifying by improving some result
of keller and kindler
it's not the result of keller in kinder
it's an improvement of the result of
keller and kinder and i will write down
later what it is
um so this tells you that you read
stationarity much much faster than you
would expect
and then step two
is to take this result and combine it
with
analysis of boolean function to prove
the theorem
all right so combine this with another
boolean function to get a sort of l one
proncare inequality that's improved by
this
by this thing and they do this using
methods of stochastic calculus
and mainly what i will try to do is to
shortcut this okay so so but but the
steps are just
i mean this is really the heart of the
theorem is what's written over here
and it it is something very very nice
and very
so um very good i don't see any
questions so i'm just going to steam it
so um what i what where i want to start
first is i want to start first by
proving
how why step one implies step two right
so i want to show you that if the
variance of ptf decays very quickly
then you already get such an inequality
okay
so um let's prove it
so
so remember what is the idea we don't
want to go all the way to time infinity
right if the variance decays very
quickly
we would just go like to go up to some
time t star because at time t star we've
already reached stationarity more or
less right and there's nothing more to
do
right so if you think back how did we
prove the l1 conquer inequality
well we did interpolation right we said
that the f minus the expectation of f
equals the integral from zero to
infinity of d dt
of ptf and then we used some simple
representation for this derivative
right so um if we don't want to go
all the way to time infinity but we just
want to go up to some time t star
well then why don't we just integrate up
to t star in the interpolation
right that's what we're going to do and
uh it gives you the following inequality
so this is an inequality rather than
having f minus the expectation of
f if i integrate only up to time t then
i just get
f minus ptf
if i let t go to infinity then ptf would
go to the expectation of f
and i will get the one ponchorani right
but let's um
let's just go up to time t then i get
the expectation of f minus ptf
and i claim this is bounded by some
constant you can get much more precise
formulas here but i'm just writing what
we need
a constant times square root t times the
expectation of the gradient of f
so this is really the same thing as um
this is really the same thing as the l
one pointer inequality except we didn't
integrate all the way up to time
infinity we just integrated up to time t
right and then you see if the time t is
very short then you do much much better
than the l1 puncher inequality
and the proof of this lemma is also the
same
okay so let's write f minus ptf
this is minus the integral from zero to
t
of dds psf
right so when we prove the one point of
inequality we just took this integral to
time infinity you know just taking it up
to time t
and then you plug in the same
probabilistic representation that we had
before
okay so this is equal to the integral
from 0 to t
of e to the minus s divided by square
root 1 minus e to the minus 2 s
exploitation c and then we had this sum
i delta i s times d
i f epsilon
d s right so this was the same
probabilistic representation we had
before
and now you do the same thing as before
you just take the absolute value and you
take the expectation
right so um
this term over here will give you the
expected gradient of f exactly like
before
and the only thing that changes is that
now we have the integral from zero to t
of this guy over here but you see for
small s
this guy is of order one over square
root s for small s right because for
small s
e to the minus s is of order one and one
minus e to the minus 2 s is of order s
right so for small s this is the order
of 1 over square root s
so if i integrate 1 over square root s
from 0 to t i get square root t
right and that's where this square root
t over here came from
right so the proof of this lemma is
identical to the proof of the one punch
inequality
all we do is we resist the temptation to
um
we resist the temptation to integrate
all the way up to infinity
and we get a slightly better result
now the problem is that we don't care
about the expectation of f minus ptf
right we still want on the left hand
side to have the variance of f
right so
i claim this is automatic so let me
write here corollary
and let me make the distinction this
lemma is true
not just for boolean functions
but for any real valued function you
have this improvement
but now i claim that for boolean
functions
to 0 1 this lemma implies
what it implies that the um
which way do i want to write it let me
write in terms of variance
the variance of f is bounded by a
constant
times square root t times the expected
gradient of f
plus the variance of ptf
and and i want to emphasize that once we
have this corollary then we're done
right with this part of the proof
because how did the proof go
right the proof had two steps right step
one was to show that the variance of ptf
is bounded by one half the variance of f
for this time
one over log of the one over the sum of
the influences squared
so let's suppose this is true right so
suppose at the time
one over log of this quantity the
variance of ptf is bounded by one half
the variance of f right
then over here on the right hand side
the variance of ptf will be bounded by
one half of the variance of f if i plug
in that time t
star so i can move it to the right hand
side right because the variance of f
minus one half the variance of f is just
a constant times the variance of f
right so then this term over here
disappears and then
over here i get this square root of t
star t star was 1
over log of 1 over the sum of the
squares of the influences
right and then i get exactly
that guy over there from this square
root t right if i divide the square of t
on the right hand side is this clear so
so so
this lemma this corollary takes care of
that
arrow over there right it just reduces
the problem to
understanding that at very short time
the variance has decreased
uh sufficiently so that you can ignore
the rest of the time evolution
so it takes care of half the problem
um i'm assuming if there are questions
about this that somebody will interrupt
me
um this is really where we
have the the disadvantage of giving
online talks beside the fact that i'm
talking to a black hole i can't see
anybody
is that you know if i'm standing in
front of a blackboard i would have all
of these slides up next to each other on
different blackboards and you could see
the formulas and you would see
immediately what i'm saying but now i
have to flip back and forth and it's a
little bit confusing
okay but i hope it was it was uh
it was enough um let me prove this
corollary
actually i claimed the corollaries
already proved in the previous lemma we
just have to realize
for boolean functions so let's take a
boolean
boolean function you can always write as
an indicator function of a sit right
it's one if if if the epsilon is an a
and zero otherwise
and let's compute what is the expected
deviation of f minus ptf
so this is so f is the indicator of a
so let me just replace that here
so just me let me just write this as the
expectation of indicator a
of indicator a minus pt indicator a plus
the expectation of indicator of a
complement
which is 1 minus indicator a times
indicator a minus
pt indicator hey all right
i've just written 1 equals 1 minus a
plus 1 in the
sorry 1 minus indicator a plus indicator
well on the set where a equals one
indicator a equals one so the first term
over here
is uh nothing else than the expectation
of
one minus sorry indicator a right what
am i saying
on the set a the absolute value of
indicator a minus pt indicator a is just
one minus b pt indicator a
so we have this and in the second term
on the event where a is not true one
minus indicator a is one exactly when a
is not true
indicator a is zero so then this
absolute value is just pt indicator a
and now what we just have to do is we
just have to expand the
the the cross terms right so we get
here um what do we get
we get the expectation of f right it's
the probability of a
minus the expectation of
f ptf
right and in the second term we get the
expectation of ptf
but remember the expectation of ptf is
just the expectation of f
by stationarity was this was this was
property 0 of the semigroup
so we get another term like this and the
second term is again the expectation of
indicator of fptf so we get a 2 here too
um now it's just a matter of rewriting
so expectation of f is not the variance
of f the variance of f is the
expectation of f minus the expectation
of f squared
right so this is two times the variance
of f
minus the expectation
of
f minus the expectation of f
p t f minus the expectation of f
so i've just added and subtracted inside
the expectation of f squared
um and now you have to remember that
pt is e to the t times the laplacian
so the expectation of f times ptg
this is the inner product of f e to the
t
times the laplacian g which is the inner
product of
f e to the t over two laplacian
e to the t over two laplacian g
and because this laplacian is symmetric
you can write this as the expectation of
p t over two f times p t over two
g okay so all i've written here is two
times the variance of f
minus the variance of p t over two
if and that's it because you see
if i plug this uh
if i plug this over here here i have two
times the variance of f
sorry this is expectation of f minus ptf
right that's this guy over here right is
equal to two times the variance of f
minus the variance of pt over 2f
right so i can get here 2 times the
variance of f less or equal constant
square of t
expectation of the gradient plus 2 times
the variance of pt over 2f
and that's exactly what i wrote over
here except i worked at time2t instead
of a time t
so i didn't really do anything over here
i just
wrote down the variant remember we had
this identity the expectation of f minus
the expectation of f
is twice the variance of if i just wrote
down the equivalent of that identity
for the expectation of the absolute
value of f minus ptf
and we got exactly this this inequality
so i'm sorry my slide is a little bit
messy but i hope it's clear that
this is a this was a very basic
computation
very good is there a question so far
so let me again emphasize that if we
know
let me write it in this slide even
though it's going to be a mess
um just because uh
uh it's easier to see when it comes it's
a request to
scroll down a bit of your your screen
slow down or move down grow down your
quick muscle
very good so good so let me
um let me just write in here
remember that the proof has two steps
step one and step two
step one was to show that i haven't done
step one yet step one is to show that
the variance of ptf
is less or equal one-half times the
value of f so we've already basically
restationarity
for t of order one
over the log of one over sum of the
expectation of d i f squared
right that was step one so let's pick
this t
right and let's plug it into this
equation right
then the on the right hand side the
variance of ptf will be bounded by one
half of the variance of f
so i can move that term to the left hand
side variance of f minus one half of the
variance of f is just
one half of the variance of f right so
then i get that the variance of f
is two times constant square root t of
the expectation
of the gradient of f for this t
so what inequality have we proved we've
proved that the variance of f
is bounded by the expected grade of f
times 1 over the square root of the log
of 1
over the sum of the influences squared
and if i move that square root from the
right hand side to the left-hand side
that is the conjecture of telegram that
was proved by eldon and goes
so this argument over here hasn't yet
shown us why it's true that boolean
functions do better than the usual
right it has just shown us that if we
can show
that um that for functions with small
influences that decay to equilibrium
goes faster than usual
then not just would you get an
improvement on the ponca rain equality
which was this result of felix
moldnitsky et cetera
but in fact you will also get an
analogous improvement of the l1
conquering quality why
because you can just do the same hack
that we did to the punk rain equality to
improve it
you can apply the same hack to the proof
of the l1 puckering
okay so um that's all we have done
good are there uh any more questions
about this
all right let me move on so what what
remains is to prove for you the step one
and um now this step one um
it has nothing to do with the rest of
what i've uh i've i've told you
um this really uses just classical
methods of boolean
of analysis of boolean functions okay
and um
um so um you know we had a theme about
using these simple probabilistic
representations to prove things and here
it allowed us to simplify this step two
um of this proof but in order to
to to wrap up the story we have to do
this step one i have to explain to you
why these type of boolean functions
behave better right why they decay
faster to equilibrium than a typical
function
and i really just have to go back to
classical techniques of boolean of
analysis of boolean functions
but so some of you may know these
techniques and if you
uh if you don't then i hope that i will
teach you something classical and the
next remaining
in my remaining time and i have prepared
several different proofs of this theorem
so we'll see it depends on how far i am
by the time i've actually stated it
which one i will you know which one i
will use
um so let's write down the theorem
so i remind you that for this step
eldon and gross use an improvement of a
result of keller kindler so let me
formulate it
so remind let me remind you that what we
need to show
i already wrote it on the previous slide
but let me remind you what we need to
show
we need to show that the variance of ptf
is bounded by one half of the variance f
right so we've already basically reached
stationarity
but when t is very very small the order
one over log
of 1 over sum i is 1 to n
of the expectation of the absolute value
of d i f
squared and there will be a constant
somewhere probably there's a constant
here too
let me put a constant
this is what we have to show
and i can write um i could write in
front of this
theorem and then you would have a
theorem right
but let me write it a little bit more
suggestively so
uh lemma whatever proposition what do
you want to call
let's call it proposition
um here it is
so for so what is this proposition
this is in a simpler form keller counter
and in this improved form
so what it says is that for boolean
functions oops
for boolean functions
and any t
let's say between let's say any t
between zero and one we're interested of
course in very small t
so um
the variance of ptf
is bounded by the variance of f times
um
sum i is 1 to n the i
expectation of the absolute value d i f
squared so whatever we have over there
in the denominator
to the power some constant times t
so um
you see the if if the variance of ptf
were bounded by e to the minus a
constant times t times the variance of f
right and you wouldn't get anything you
just get a constant one
but here we get something larger than
one inside the brackets
which is the improvement and why does
that imply this inequality over here
um why does that imply this inequality
over here
well some you know sum of influences
squared to the power ct
is just e to the power of ct times log
of the sum of influences squared so if i
take t to be
1 over that log then this second term
over here will just become a constant
right and i can make it as small as i
want by picking the constant as small as
i want
right so for t sufficiently small right
so
maybe i should be pedantic right this
term over here is just equal to
e to the c t log
of c sum i's one to n
maybe i have neither one over somewhere
i probably need a one over somewhere
let me check
or minus ct in the exponent ah that
would help a lot
no uh it should be c times t that
shouldn't be minus ct
or minus ct in the exponent um
now i'm confusing myself greatly
the variance should definitely be going
down as t increases
the variance should be going down as t
increases
so maybe i need it with a minus t
no no but this this this quantity over
here of course this is good when it's
small so it's less than one
right um right so we should think of
this quantity over here as being less
than one
right so let's write it like good so
thank you for the help
i should write this as e to the minus ct
times the log of 1 over sum i
is 1 to n of the expectation the if
squared
there we go right
i have minus log of 1 over something
and now if i pick t to be 1 divided by
this thing times a constant
a sufficiently large constant right
then i get e to the minus sufficiently
large constant and i just have to choose
the constant sufficiently large that
this e to the minus that thing is less
or equal one
and then i get this statement over here
at the top
right so if i choose t to be
if i choose t to be this thing i have
too many constants but if i choose t to
be something like this then this log
over here cancels
right i will get a constant from here so
there's a constant there so i should
have a constant there
right so these constants whenever i
write c it's a different constant okay
so because i keep forgetting which one
i'm choosing
right but if i do t to be one divided by
this times a constant i just get e to
the minus
a constant right and i'm allowed to pick
that constant as large as i want because
i can pick this constant over here as
large as i want
and so i can make this less than one
right and that's why we get
this statement over here so um
so what i really need to prove is i need
to prove this proposition over here
um which
which is more yeah which which which is
the right thing
so um
let's see now i have about 10 minutes
so um very good we will go to the short
proof um let me i want to do two things
so so
um the proof of this theorem
um or proposition if you will
um it just depends how you do it depends
on where you start
so um i've prepared a proof completely
from scratch without assuming any
background whatsoever
um but i don't have time to do it all in
10 minutes
and that was what i feared which is why
i prepared several proofs
so what i would like to do i think the
most efficient usage of our time
is that i first give you some general
intuition for those of you who have
never thought about such questions
before
i give you some general intuition why
theorems like this
are true okay and this intuition is is
is a very useful intuition to have in
your head
it is usually derived from a property
called hypercontractivity
um but you don't need to and i i want to
explain to you this intuition uh about
why you get such why do you get such
quick convergence just
converge as a time little one i want to
give you a little bit of general
intuition why you should expect that for
boolean functions
then i will probably only have five
minutes left so then rather than
showing you how to develop this
intuition from scratch
i fear that um i promised you i'm going
to prove everything i do
from scratch but i can't do it in five
minutes so what i will do is the very
last five minutes of my lectures
i will just give a proof for the experts
okay
you can you can run over time a little
bit i can run over time the problem is
that you know i will run over time by
about 15 to 20 minutes probably and
that's uh i
you know i don't want people to tire out
for jalani's talk so maybe what what
would be
okay here's my proposal i'm going to
give you some general intuition that
everybody should understand
then i'm going to give you a five minute
proof of this for the experts basically
this follows in three lines from hyper
contractivity plus the theorem of alex
munich
okay so i'll show that that's easy right
um then you see that this theorem
follows sort of from
well-known results um and then if people
want in the question answer session i
can
do a short version of the complete of
the from scratch proof
where maybe i skip some steps which are
very standard but i will at least give
you some intuition about
um how you can think of this without
just hitting it with standard tools okay
so is that
does that seem reasonable then hopefully
there will be enough time to decompress
before generally stock
okay let's do it let me give you some
intuition uh
let me let me again make up a name for
it
it's the arithmetic mean geometric mean
principle
so i want to try to explain to you why
you can expect that boolean functions
um will uh uh will reach
well why the semigroup will each reach
equilibrium for boolean functions
much much quicker than you would then
you would have it in general for
for example a linear function okay and i
want to explain some sort of general
intuition for why it's true
from this intuition it's not 100 obvious
how to go to the proposition
it requires a few more steps okay but
let's let's let me discuss this amg
so um remember that
in the let's not think about boolean
functions but let's think for a moment
about functions from the discrete cube
that are non-negative boolean functions
when they take the value zero and one
are non-negative so this is a useful
picture to have in your mind and
remember that the poincare inequality
says something about
exponential decay so let me use for a
moment this corner here at scratch paper
the the um the poncho inequality says
something about the exponential decay of
the semi-grouped
equilibrium it says something like
variance of ptf is bounded by e to the
minus 2t
times the variance of now if you
write out what this is so you could
express this in terms of the expectation
of the gradient square this turns out to
be equivalent
okay now if you rearrange this if you
write the variance of the expectation of
the square
minus the expectation of the function
squared then
um what you get
is something like this you get that the
expectation of ptf
squared is bounded by e to the minus 2t
times the expectation of f
squared plus 1 minus e to the minus 2t
times the expectation of f squared
okay this is just rewriting this
inequality over here
right i've just expanded the definition
of the variance on both sides and i've
used that the expectation of ptf is
equal to the expectation of it
so what you see from this formula is
that the poncarene equality implies that
at any time t
the very or the the size of ptf of the
semi group
it interpolates which we already knew
this is how we derived the poincare
inequality
the semi group interpolates between the
expectation of f squared and the
expectation of f
squared right that's exactly what the
semi group does
and it does so in an arithmetic mean
like this
so for example for small t this is
something like expectation of f squared
plus t
times the expectation of f's now
what was special about boolean functions
for boolean functions the expectation of
f's the expectation of f squared this
term
tends to be at least that the
probability is small this term will be
much much smaller than that term
right that tends to be what happens for
boolean functions
but this this inequality of arithmetic
mean
doesn't actually uh help us right
because suppose this is very small
right suppose this is even zero just for
heck of it of course it can't be if it's
not negative but suppose this is even
zero
just for the heck of it um in order to
pick at time
t right this term over here will be of
order 1 minus t or 1 minus 2t
so in order to pick a time t where this
is less than one half of that
i would still need to have a time t of
order one right because this is an
arithmetic mean
now on the other hand we could have the
following dream
maybe we could improve this inequality
maybe instead of having an arithmetic
mean we could have a geometric mean
something like this
of course i couldn't have it with the
same coefficients because the inequality
for arithmetic and geometric means goes
the other way
but maybe with some slightly better
coefficient worse coefficients
we could have um
we can have a geometric mean rather than
an arithmetic
now you see that um now you see that we
do much better because now you see
this can be written equivalently right
as
the expectation of f squared times the
expectation of
f divided by the expectation of f
squared like this
1 minus e to the minus t right so
if for boolean functions we argue that
this is often very very small
so if that is very very small then we
could choose t
to be very very very small in order to
still get just the constant in front
and that would exactly help us right so
the picture that you should have in mind
is that if here is expectation of f
squared and somewhere very close to zero
the expectation of f squared
right then
this e to the minus two t right you you
have this this is the ponca inequality
and you would still need to have time t
of order one
in order to reach one half of the
expectation of squid
but the arithmetic mean the sorry the
geometric mean goes to zero
much much quicker right it reaches one
half over here at time
of order log of the expectation of
uh f squared divided by the expectation
of f squared or
minus 1 over this something like that
right which when this becomes very very
small
it's probably one over this so when this
becomes very very small
this this will be uh you you know you
will have a time of
order little low so these type of
phenomena tend to happen because
um you can replace an arithmetic mean by
geometric mean
now this seems very suspicious but the
beautiful thing is that this dream is a
reality
and i just for sake of giving it the
name i called it the amgm principle
it turns out that this convergence to
equilibrium for non-negative functions
actually happens in a much better way
than you expect it doesn't doesn't just
happen in a sort of
geometric sorry arithmetic mean way it
happens in a kind of geometric mean way
and this is really the phenomenon this
is an improvement over
how we usually think about ergodicity
and it's really this phenomenon over
here
that um that is the the cause
of all of these improvements of the
poncare inequality
and usually this this reality is proved
from an even stronger
uh usually
this is proved using an even stronger
statement
which is called hypercontractivity
but you don't need to prove it using
hyperconnectivity you can prove it
directly by hand and in fact you get
something slightly better than you can
prove using hypercontractivity
which i never noticed until i was
preparing this lecture um
but you could prove such an inequality
directly by hand and it would explain
why this
why this phenomenon happens but if you
take this phenomenon for granted then
you can
then you can um then you can expect uh
um
you can expect the type of things to
happen that that happen
let me um uh very very quickly indicate
to you to the expert so i'm going to
take like three minutes for the experts
and then uh
you know you can ask me questions and if
there's time i can give you some
intuition from scratch
about why you get this amg in principle
but let me
um where was my slide let me very
quickly
argue to you where this proposition
comes from
without going from scratch so let's copy
paste it
oops
so if we don't go from scratch but we
just try to
um prove it directly i want to argue
that this is in some sense just an
integrated form of the proof of the
result of falex malnitsky and rossignol
okay so i i didn't just give you that
form for nothing
remember that falex moudmetski rossignol
said that the variance of function f
times log of variance of f divided by
sum of the expectation d i f
squared is bounded by some constant
times the expectation
of df squared right this was the the the
improvement on the punch inequality so
this is a known result it's a kkl type
result there's another constant
somewhere maybe here
so this is a kkl type result and i claim
that this inequality is essentially an
integrated form of this inequality
okay let's check what is ddt of variance
of ptf
this we already computed because this is
exactly how we computed the
interpolation formula um in the proof of
the poncare inequality
right this is just minus the expectation
of
the gradient of ptf squared and now you
can just plug this inequality over here
here we have the expectation of the
gradient square plug this formula in for
ptf
right so you will get that this is
bounded by one over a constant
times the variance of ptf times log
of the variance of ptf divided by
the constant times the sum of the
expectation
d i
d i p t f squared
right um there's a minus i forgot a
minus
because there's a minus here um now
this p t over here you can just remove
it by jensen inequality the inequality
goes the correct direction so let's
pretend like this guy over here doesn't
depend on pt
right that's the jensen inequality will
go the correct direction to get rid of
the hakka
okay so this term is what we want and
now you have your differential
inequality for ddt of the variance of
ptf
right and you just do calculus right you
you do the chain rule apply it to log of
the variance of ptf this variance will
cancel here you have another log of the
variance of ptf
right so just by by uh by calculus
simple calculus will give you the
inequality the variance of ptf
is bounded by the variance of f times e
to the minus t
uh and then times constant the sorry
there's severe constant here probably
times constant sum i of the expectation
d i
f
squared times 1 minus e to the minus t
right so this is just integrating this
differential inequality and now it looks
like we're almost done
except there's a little issue if we
write this as the variance of f
times something like in the result right
it's a variance of f times something
the variance of f times c times sum i is
1 to n
of the expectation d i f
squared divided by the variance of f
1 minus e to the minus t over c
okay um oops
1 minus e to the minus t
and the issue is that in this i don't
know why that doesn't erase
the issue is that in the in the
inequality
there is no one divided by the variance
of f in here
on the other hand we haven't yet used
that f is a boolean function
right this inequality i proved here is
true for any function
right so um we haven't yet used that f
is a boolean function
so now you just distinguish two cases
one of them is where var
if the variance of f is greater or equal
let's say the square root of some i is
one to n
of the expectation d i f squared
right then you can just remove this
variance of f over here you'll just get
a square root right and that's fine
because 1 minus e to the minus t over c
is just still of order t if i put a one
half in front of it
right on the other hand since the
variance of f is
upper bounded by this thing right then
you can just directly apply hyper
connectivity because then you can just
say that the expectation of ptf
sorry the variance of ptf
ptf by hypercontractivity
is bounded by the variance of f to the
some power this is like something like
one plus ot
right and then if you apply this
inequality then you're done
so that's the proof very quickly for the
experts
unfortunately not from scratch but if
people want to hear me give a sort of uh
a very quick explanation about how you
would prove this from scratch i'm very
happy to do it so
um let me end there i would like to
thank the organizers very much for
inviting me and
uh in particular um i only noticed it at
the very end of the third lecture
that there is this q a and organizers
rather than
you know just sitting back and snoozing
during my talk
seem to have been very very active in
answering questions on my behalf i
really really appreciate it so thank you
very much for both of those things
um and let me answer thanks
okay vermont thank you so much for these
beautiful lectures um
so there we do still have some questions
uh
uh claymond is your microphone working
okay actually clear i think clement's
microphone is not working so he had two
questions
um uh first question
uh he said this is maybe orthogonal to
the focus of this lecture but
can these techniques similarly be used
to give alternate proofs of the level 1
or level k inequalities
for boolean functions and for gaussian
um
unfortunately clement i i do not have
the exact definitions of level one and
level two inequalities in my head
which makes it hard to answer the
question um
i learned about these two names from a
talk by ronin about this paper
and i i have promptly forgotten what
they think what these things mean
if i recall correctly they can be proved
rather easily
using not these techniques but actually
using the same type of techniques that
we use probabilistic representation
um that we um that we use to prove the
vector-valued inequalities
um yeah maybe i'll comment on that yes
please hold on yes
yeah so yeah somehow especially in
gaussian
space the level k inequalities are are
somehow
simpler than those inequalities they
basically say
that um the if if you want to maximize
the case
moment given a measure this is done on
half spaces
and and like you you have a much
simpler geometric proof of that actually
okay moment of the semi group no no
no no no no just just the integral of x
to the k
or over like or or the norm of the k
tensor over a set so just just think of
the
level one inequality is just the inter
integral of x over a set
given the met if you fix the measure of
a set this is maximized for a half space
and i mean somehow
using these methods to prove these
inequalities
i don't know if you can do it but even
if you can this is
a total overkill because these
inequalities are usually much
simpler but in fact the other way around
is true
you can use uh moment inequalities to
prove
uh these inequalities in a way that kind
of
bypasses hypercontractivity which was
used by ramon in in a certain sense
at least quoting the you know result of
uh
of uh i don't remember the the names
alex yeah
yeah okay i mean all of this can be
proved uh by hand
very quickly but but um but one you know
the proof i have in mind sort of
emulates hyper contractivity just much
simpler right you don't need full hyper
connectivity
to prove this result you only need a
very special case which is much easier
to prove
but yes
yeah answered much better than i would
have been able to i
i the problem is i don't know exactly
what's the name instead of this special
case of hyper contractivity you could
replace it by the so-called level one
inequality
it doesn't matter that much i guess at
least for this
if this is what you're trying to achieve
it doesn't matter that much
what was the second question nike uh the
second question is about the proposition
here
uh is it true only for t at most one
um no okay let me write down what i
could prove
i just wrote t at most one because you
see really in the exponent i don't have
t
i have e to the minus t over c and t e
to the t over c
and i just wanted to replace this by a
constant times t which is why i wrote
that just for simplest probably i don't
need it at all but it was just simpler
for me
you know for small t one minus e to the
minus t is of order t
right so that's all that's the only
reason i wrote t less than one
um here is what i could prove uh
by hand the variance of ptf
is bounded by the variance of f times
2 times the square root some i is one to
n
of the expectation d i f
squared to the power of
some function theta t okay and this is
true for all t
and this function theta t that i ended
up with but i have to look it up
is log
of 2 over 1 plus e to the minus 2t
divided by log 2.
whatever this function is this function
is of order t
small t right and that's so that's
that's what this inequality is
and the only funny thing about this
statement which is just uh you know
i'm not claiming this is the optimal
statement that's what naturally came out
of the proof that i wrote down from
scratch
and the only funny thing i would like to
emphasize about it is that this function
theta t is strictly better than what you
can get from hyperconjugativity
and somehow if you prove this simpler
simpler consequence of hyperconductivity
from scratch you find out that
hyper connectivity is sub-optimal for
this amgm principle you can actually do
better than hyper conductivity this was
a surprise to me i didn't know that
but i cannot think of any reason why you
would care but uh
this is a funny consequence but but this
is what i could prove without any
attempt at doing any better
um and uh and you see this is true for
all ts so there's nothing
you know nothing magical about t between
zero and one except i wanted to say that
it's function theta t of
the order big o of t so you know for
small t
so that's why i said t less or equal to
one but probably this function is just
bounded by a constant times t
for all t and then you would be fine um
can that be true no because this term is
so i i don't know
i i have to think about but certainly
for t less than one you would have such
a bound right and that's
why i for you know just to be sure i
wrote down t list
now we're interested in this for very
small t right because if t's of order
one you can't improve on the puncher
inequality
right so you don't really care about
this thing when he is large
all right is there another question
there are but if you maybe now is a good
time to give a description of the
alternate group
okay let me just give you a very quick
rundown and and and
i will skip some standard steps okay
um mostly what i want to to explain
is the intuition why is this amg in
principle true right
so um
so can we understand the mechanism that
causes it right
without for the moment worrying so much
about the you know the details
and um actually it's very easy to
understand let's think about the case
n equals one
okay so we have a function from zero one
so we have a discrete cube of dimension
one
two r plus and in this case remember we
had an explicit formula for ptf
ptf was equal to e to the minus t times
f
plus 1 minus e to the minus t times the
expectation of if
okay this is just the explicit formula
for the one dimension this is the random
walk in dimension one right it was
something very simple
before the first time that the clock
rings which happens by time t with
probability e to minus t
nothing happens and after that we've
replaced it by an independent copy
so from this if you compute the
expectation of ptf squared at just the
trivial computation
you get that this is equal to e to the
minus t of the expectation of f square
plus 1 minus e to the minus 2t times the
xbo
times the expectation of
f oops i don't know what just happened
so we get uh expectation of ptf
squared is equal to e to the minus 2t
of the expectation of f squared plus 1
minus e to the minus 2t
times the expectation of f now you might
worry that we're completely screwed
because remember what was the intuition
this thing that i just wrote down is
true in one dimension that's what we
would get from the poincare inequality
right with an inequality but i just
claimed that in dimension one this is
true of equality
right so in dimension one
you have not an uh geometric mean you
have an arithmetic mean with equality
right which seems like we're screwed you
can't upper bound an arithmetic
a geometric sorry an arithmetic mean by
a geometric mean right the arithmetic
mean geometric mean inequality goes the
other way
right so for example if i have two
numbers a and b
right the arithmetic mean
right it's always lower bounded by the
geometric mean
but you can never expect to have such an
inequality
right for example what happens if b
equals zero right if b
equals zero the right hand side is zero
but the left-hand side is not zero
right so you can never hope to reverse
the arithmetic mean geometric mean
inequality in general
but it turns out you can reverse the
arithmetic mean geometric mean
inequality
if you assume that that can't happen
what i just said right so here is a
simple exercise
okay about so let's reverse
the arithmetic mean geometric mean
inequality okay
so uh my claim is that if you assume
that a
and b cannot be too far apart so for
example b is upper bounded by
a upper bounded by let's say 2b
okay so if a and b cannot be too far
apart
then for lambda between 0 and 1
the arithmetic mean one minus lambda a
plus lambda b is upper bounded by a to
the one minus mu b to the mu
for mu being a function of lambda
is log of
1 over 1 minus lambda over 2 divided by
log 2. and of course this function
should look familiar to you from what i
just wrote that's exactly the function
if you choose lambda to be something
like 1 minus e to the minus 2t
that's exactly the function i wrote out
for the amg
so and this is a simple exercise you
just notice that first of all divide
both sides by
by b okay so divide both sides by b
then you just have something as a
function of a ratio of a and b
right which is between uh uh one and two
right and then if you subtract the
left-hand side from the right-hand side
this is a concave function so it's
minimized that one of the
it's a concave function of a over b it's
minimized that's one of the endpoints
and you can just check that this mu is
the best you can do
right so this is very simple so in order
to apply this in dimension one
what would you need you would need to
show that the expectation of
f squared well obviously this is always
bounded by the expectation of f squared
this is jensen
but in order to apply this reverse amg
integral you'd have to show that this is
bounded by 2 times the expectation of a
squared all right well in general this
is not true of course but it is true on
the one dimensional discrete cube
right because in the one dimensional
discrete cube this is f of one
plus squared plus f of minus one squared
over two
well that's certainly bounded by f of
one
plus f of minus one squared over two
and that's exactly this right
so this where where does the discrete
cube help us the discrete cube is very
discrete it only has two points
and in a two-dimensional in r2 the l1
norm and the l2 norm
are comparable with a constant factor
here in this square root 2.
this is not true in a general um in in
r3 for example the console would have
been a three in rn it would have to
depend on n
but in r2 it's very simple because you
have a direct comparison between the one
and o2 norm and r2
and that means you can reverse the am gm
inequality right
which shows that this geometric beam can
be upper sorry this arithmetic beam can
be upper bounded by a geometric mean
some function 1 minus theta of t
times expectation of f squared times
theta t and this function theta of t
just comes directly from this
from this state so this is in dimension
one
but once you have it in dimension one
then you can use a standard idea on the
discrete cube you can just tensorize
this inequality together the dimension
in
so what you do is if i have an
n-dimensional if they have the
n-dimensional problem
right remember these semi-group acts is
just the expectation over independent
coordinates of the function
so i can just take the expectation one
one entry at a time
apply the one-dimensional inequality do
holders inequality and then do it over
and over again and i will get the same
inequality in dimension n so i'm
skipping this part
but this is a standard trick on the
discrete cube that once you have a
one-dimensional inequality that's like
this
you can tensorize it and you get in any
dimension with all of the same constants
and everything
and that gives you this amgm principle
and dimension in
now then to go from there
to so this gives you um
this gives you this for example this
second step over here in the proof you
can get directly from this amg
inequality but to get this first step in
the proof you have to prove something
else right so what i've just shown you
is that the variance of ptf
is bounded by the variance of f to
something like 1 minus
constant times t times the expectation
of f minus the expectation of f
to the power constant times t something
like this right
but i still need to replace this by the
sum of the expectation
of d
i f squared right
and here what you do in order to do that
is you combine
this inequality with the proof of the
efronstein inequality
and this is exactly the trick that is
used in the paper of alex marinitsky and
rossignol
it's exactly that trick what you do is
you write so for those of you who know
you can always write
f minus the expectation of f as as a
martingale as a sum i is 1 to n
of the x when i take the expectation
over e i plus 1
to epsilon n of f minus when i take the
expectation over epsilon
i to epsilon n of f so i've written
f minus the expectation of f as a
martingale
and the variance of f is exactly the sum
i is 1 to n
of the expectation of the square of
these guys because it's a martingale
and what you can do is you can plug
these terms over here into this
inequality
and then you get exact immediately from
that simple trick
you get this first inequality over here
that's it that's the whole proof so it's
really two types of tensorization
once you have a reverse amg inequality
in one dimension
you can tensorize that in the usual way
the same way that you would tensorize
hypercontractivity for example
and at the same time from that amgm
principle you can tensorize in a second
way you can apply the martingale trick
in the proof of ephronstein
and that will immediately get you this
the sum of the influences squared
and so this was very quick i realized
that to actually write down all the
details would take me more time but it
wouldn't introduce any new ideas right
it's just
it gives you an idea about how you can
prove this thing completely from scratch
and every step is a very natural very
simple principle that we know how to do
on boolean cube
so that's the proof i had in mind but
but you know to dot all the i's across
the t's will take me some time
but it's not really any harder than what
i did over
that's it that's that was my spiel
okay thank you so much so we're going to
take a very short break and then we'll
come back in about
uh eight minutes for jalani's talk
thanks again thank you